Personality traits are dispositions to behave in a particular over time. So,
traits are connected directly to the disposition to behave. Let's look in an
example. Here we see Miriam and Biriam. Miriam is usually very friendly. Watch.
See, someone cut her in the lunch line and she was nice about it. She holds the
door for people when they're walking in. Someone even hits her car when they
weren't paying attention. She was less nice to the person in this situation,
but tried to be understanding. Someone gave her a million dollars and she was
extra nice to them. Now let's go to Biriam, who's usually not very friendly.
Somebody cut him in line and he rudely makes them know how wrong they were to
cut him. Someone's walking up and he doesn't hold the door for them. Someone
hits his car when they weren't paying attention and he's really, really rude
about it. Someone gives him a million dollars and then we see him be kind of
nice to that person.